اصحاب المشاريع هنا يتشابهون مع نظرائهم
في الولايات المتحده يتطلعون الى شيئين
افكار محفوظه الحقوق لكي لا يتمكن احد من
سرقه ابداعاتهم دون دفع رسوم عليها وراس
المال يعينهم على تنفيذ خططهم ولذا فان
فكره جمع اصحاب المال مع المبدعين يعتبر
فرصه للانطلاق
والنمو الرئيس اوباما ركز على صندوق مالي
لمصر وتونس الا ان كلا الدولتين في مرحله
انتقاليه ما يجعل انشاء مشاريع صغيره امرا
صعبا خصوصا وسط الفوضه السياسيه
هناك هذا سبب وجودنا هنا وهذا سبب وجود
فرص للاستثمار فانشاء صندوق مالي في كل من
مصر وتونس لم يكن بسبب وفره رؤوس المال بل
ندرتها نريد الذهاب الى حيث توجد المشاكل
والفرص وما من شك بان هناك اراده عمل لدى
الشباب في كل من مصر وتونس وفكره هذا
الصندوق هي توجيه المال لمن لديه افكار
ورغبه اضافه الى قدرته على خلق سو لهذه
الافكار باسرع وقت ممكن ومع ذلك هل تقر
بان الفوضه السياسيه تدفع الاستثمارات
الاجنبيه بعيدا ولا تعالج المشاكل
الاساسيه للربيع العربي والتي تكمن في
بطاله الشباب وقله الفرص دعني اضع هذا في
المنظور الصحيح الحكومه المصريه على راس
عملها منذ خمسه شهور الحكومه التونسيه
الجديده لازالت تعيد كتابه الدستور منذ
قرابه السنه فبناء الديمقراطيه اصعب من
انجاز الثوره هذا الامر سيتطلب بعض الوقت
وهذا لا يمنع من الاستثمار حاليا وهذا هو
سبب استثمارنا في هذا الوقت المبكر سنكون
متواجدين بعد عام او عامين من الان ولكن
كما تعلم فان استثمار المشاريع يتطلب راس
المال والصبر اضافه الى الثبات وهذا ما
نحاول
تحقيقه كما تعلم فان السمه السائده في هذه
المنطقه هي ان تلعب الحكومه دورا كبيرا في
قطاع الاعمال بشكل قد يحد من دور القطاع
الخاص وهذا يشكل تحديا كبيرا اذ ان ما
يقرب من 80% من الوظائف تعتمد على
الحكومات وهذا يجب ان يتغير فكريا للبدء
من النقطه التي تنطلق
منها هذا صحيح بكل تاكيد في كثير من الدول
التي نتعامل معها ولكن انظر الى الامارات
العربيه المتحده اليوم اذ ان لديها روحا
عاليه في استثمار المشاريع في كل من دبي
وابو ظبي ولذا نحن هنا اليوم هذه الوظائف
لم تخلق من قبل الحكومه فقط بل بمساعده
اصحاب المشاريع الذين ياتون هنا للاستثمار
ايضا وعندما تنظر الى بلدان مثل تونس
وليبيا ومصر فان الحكومه لعبت دورا كبيرا
في كل من هذه الدول الا ان هناك رغبه
متزايده من قبل اصحاب المشاريع لايجاد
الاسواق وخلق المال وهذا ما نحاول القيام
به عن طريق المؤتمرات الدوليه لاصحاب
المشاريع هل تعتقد فعلا ان التيارات
الاسلاميه التي وصلت الى السلطه ستتبنى
الاعمال والمشاريع وستت قبل ما كنت تتحدث
عنه هنا المتمثل في مجتمع يعتمد
الاستثمارات والمبادرات
الفرديه ليس لديهم خيار فالناس في كل
لديهم مشكله واحده يريدون اعاله عائلاتهم
ويريدون الحصول على وظائف وتلقي التعليم
هذه الحكومات يجب عليها التفاعل مع شعوبها
هذه هي مهمتنا وان لم يتحقق ذلك فلن تعود
الى الحكم بعد ذلك الامر بهذه البساطه لذا
واقعيا لدينا الثقه بانه مع ازياد نضوج
هذه الحكومات والتوصل الى دساتير جديده
فانها ستعمل مع شعبها بشكل اكبر وهنا تكمن
الفرصه to give them the opportunities
that's what this opportunity is about